-Welcome back.
-Yeah, it's good to see you.
-I'm very happy
to have you here.
I want to ask you a question,
get right into it.
Obviously you were
critical of the President
when you ran against him
during the primaries in 2016,
said things about how he had an
insatiable desire for attention,
how there were things about him
that you didn't like.
How do you feel like
it's been going?
[ Laughter ]
-There hasn't been a big change.
-No.
It seems very in line with
how we thought it would go.
-You know, my job, Seth,
is to talk about the policy
and always try to stay away from
name calling or personality.
Look, the country
is frankly more divided today,
or has settled in --
Hard left, hard right.
Neither side listens
to the other side.
So all we're focusing on now
is the middle,
those people who are not
hard right or hard left.
And I'll tell you
who else I focus on --
The Gen Xers
and the Millennials.
They're the hope for the future
for our country.
There isn't any question.
They're comfortable
with America's role
in the world.
They don't want
all this conflict.
They don't want name calling.
They just want it to work.
So I have a lot of faith
in the Millennials.
I think they are the future,
and they are committed
to improving our country.
-Do you feel like --
[ Cheers and applause ]
-And it's community up.
Here's the other thing, see,
we're all focused
on the President, okay.
What's the president doing?
I mean, really, does the
President affect you every day?
What affects you every day
are your neighbors, your job.
Right? Those are the things --
-I can't stress how much
he affects my job every day.
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah. For you.
-Yeah, yeah.
-For guys in your business...
-I'm an outlier. I'm an outlier.
-Yeah, you're right.
-I'm an outlier.
-But don't you think coming
from New Hampshire like you did
with the town halls
and the way it works,
it should be bottom up.
-Mm-hmm.
-So everybody in this audience
needs to make --
you think this is politics.
It's not. Okay?
Everybody here
needs to do something
to bring some improvement
where they live.
Don't wait for the big boss
or the President or anybody.
You do it.
Because if we don't do that,
we lose the essence of what
our country's all about.
-That's a very good point.
[ Cheers and applause ]
I think that is a --
what about, you know,
obviously there was --
it was a big field that ran
against Donald Trump in 2016.
A lot of the people
were critical of him
the same way you were.
But they have since
joined his cabinet.
They have since returned
to the Senate
or the House and support him
and his legislation.
If you were in a position,
obviously, as a governor,
you have to deal with him less,
but if you were in the House,
if you were in the Senate
right now,
how would you approach
being a Republican
dealing with Donald Trump?
-Well, I think, you know,
Seth, I've been a sort of
an iconoclast all of my career.
See, look, when I got in,
my job was not to report to the
Republican National Committee.
And I don't think it should,
to be a Democrat,
to report to the
Democratic National Committee.
You happen to be a Republican
because you're for
less government,
you're a Democrat for X.
But at the end,
I have to do a job.
I mean, I have to look myself
in the mirror.
And it doesn't matter to me what
the partisans want me to do.
And, so, you know, my focus
every day is economic growth,
jobs, but there's
another thing.
You can't just have prosperity
touching people at the top.
Everybody has to feel it.
So in our state,
we expanded Medicaid.
I want healthcare for people.
You imagine if you didn't have
any healthcare,
what your life would be like?
I want our people
in the minority community
to feel as though
they got a shot.
I'm sick of politics,
aren't you?
I mean, I'm sick of politics!
Okay.
[ Cheers and applause ]
So let's --
what I try to do is
let's look at a problem
and go and fix it,
and that's all you can do.
So I served for a long time
in Washington,
18 years as a congressman.
Sometimes I worked against my
own President and my own party.
Okay? So what?
If I have --
I fought to balance the budget.
I had to fight at times the
first President Bush on that.
So what? I mean,
there were a lot of reforms.
When we reformed welfare
for poor people,
I said,
"Well, we should reform welfare
for rich people
in corporations."
What's fair is fair.
So if you operate
with a compass,
you operate
with a set of values,
the jobs are not that hard.
And when you get heat, so what?
So, for me, think about this,
we had the convention
in Ohio, okay?
I didn't go.
It was in my own state.
-Yeah.
-People were, like, outraged.
-Sure.
-I didn't endorse him.
You know,
I wrote in John McCain --
my hero, John McCain.
-Mm-hmm.
-A great guy.
And, so, at the end,
people, today, still
are angry with me.
And this wasn't
because I was upset
because something happened
to me.
It was not the values
I believed in.
Last point -- I wrote
a book called "Two Paths."
You know, look, we have a lot
of trouble in this country.
You can either look at people
who are struggling
and you can --
you can make excuses,
you can demagogue them
and make them more negative,
or you can look at them
and say,
"Look, you got problems,
I agree.
Let's go fix them together."
So it's a difference
between negative populism
and positive populism.
I want to give people hope.